oh father  we must speak with you urgently  my friends where's odin  father has fallen into the odin sleep  mother fears he may never awaken again  we would speak with her she has refused  to leave my father's bedside  you can bring your urgent matter to me  your king  my king we would ask that you end thor's  punishment  my first command cannot be to undo the  all-father's last  we're on the brink of war with the  otenheim  our people need a sense of continuity in  order to feel safe in these difficult  times  all of us must stand together for the  good of asgard  yes of course good then you will wait  for my word  if i may i beg the indulgence of  your majesty to perhaps reconsider we're  done  you